[Music]
friday morning what's cool at school
well in an increasingly divided world
the kids over at hayes elementary are
learning that kindness pays off
literally the pta vice president beth
knew it she explains a fundraiser there
where the kids are not selling anything
each student registers online and then
is able to send emails to
friends family requesting donations and
then instead of
selling something the kids basically
just request the donation and then
they're paying it forward with acts of
kindness assistant principal michelle
tone student today told me they helped
their
mom make their bed today pta president
stacy johnson it was so fun just to hear
the kids say simple things even like
smile at somebody or go sit next to
somebody who doesn't have a friend to
sit next to you third grader maeve knew
it i like making
colorful colorful
cards and
making crafts for people fourth grader
liam johnson sometimes i read it to my
little sister i only have two sisters
but i tell you what liam i have a couple
of sisters myself it's hard it's hard to
be nice to yourself
hayes elementary principal lindsey
packer the one thing that really stood
out to me when we were talking about it
today i went into a classroom and asked
the students and he said well i brought
something some chocolate for my teacher
and i said that's wonderful and i said
but how did it make you feel and so
really
instilling the fact that by doing nice
things for people and being kind really
the point is to make you feel good about
it how about that so it's called the
raise craze fundraiser over at hayes
elementary we have a link to that in the
online version of this story and also
just for the record for young liam and
all the great folks over at hayes on
that zoom call it's not hard to be nice
to my sisters there's deb and there's
nikki all right if you know something
cool at school let us know head over to
8newsnow.com find the community tab
that's where you'll find cool at school
or send us an email cool at school at
8newsnow.com